more than two billion years before the
proto-molecule was discovered in our
solar system
it was created by an advanced
civilization we refer to
as the ring builders capital r capital b
we don't know what planet the ring
builder civilization developed on or
what their home system
is but we do know that over what is
probably a very long period of time
they became much more technologically
advanced than humans
they mastered space flight they gained
an understanding of wormholes
and were able to utilize those for
faster than light travel
from there they started building a
massive network of
ring gates which connected several
systems
inside the milky way which all had at
least one
habitable planet this allowed their
civilization to thrive
and in the process of building that
network using the proto molecule for the
construction of the ring gates they sent
what was essentially
an icy rock loaded with protomolecule on
a trajectory towards earth
long before advanced life had developed
this got caught in saturn's gravity
and stayed there for a couple billion
years it looked like a moon we named it
phoebe
and it just sat there in orbit full of
proto-molecule just waiting to be
discovered
the fact that it got captured may have
been necessary for human life to develop
in this scenario
and while it was stuck there the ring
builder civilization that sent it were
completely wiped out
somehow they got themselves in the
sights of an even more advanced
civilization
which we refer to as the unknown
aggressors
this may be related to the ringgate
network that they created but we don't
know for sure by the end of the fifth
book or the fifth season of the
television show
we just know that something set the
unknown aggressors off
and they did end the ring builder
civilization
so as far as humanity's concerned the
expanse happens in our solar system in
the future
there's no point of divergence or
something like that
basically the history we know still
exists there's nothing to contradict
that but it takes place
in the 24th century so i guess just for
context when i say that phoebe's been
trapped
for two billion plus years if we think
about humans
modern humans first showed up about 200
000 years ago so the protomolecule and
the ring builder stuff was happening way
before we existed
when we think of the present in the
story pinning down the years always been
a little bit murky
they never mention dates in the books
and there's this weird thing where they
put the 23rd century
in the text crawl in the first episode
of the series which is weirdly probably
not right
so this is what i'm going to do the best
theory has always been that the show
starts in the year 2350
because that was the name given to the
role playing game this was developed
from
in season 5 we do see some dates for the
first time on
a time lapse in the opening credits and
it ends with 23.55
so that would fit with the 23.50 time
passes a little bit faster in the tv
show so that would mean that it's been
about five years since the series
started
compared to something like 10 in the
books either way that's the way i'm
gonna do it so the canterbury say
happens in 2350. and in that they're
just estimations
and so we can move around and think
about how things relate to each other
and it's easier than using a before
protomolecule after protomolecule scale
because that's discovered eight years
before the series gets started
not long after our present the
colonization of mars gets underway in
the expanse universe
over the next hundred years or so the
population of earth continues to swell
ecological and climate disasters
compound
and the damage to the ecosystem of earth
starts to reach critical levels
this leads to a shift in the development
of space travel technologies
and this is probably when development on
luna really started to take off
during this period the united nations
becomes earth's unified government
after a few generations of being a u.n
colony the people on mars
who were largely self-sufficient by that
time started to push for independence
there were actually tensions here and
there was a real chance for
war it's kind of similar to the events
of the american revolution
the american colonies in great britain
and there may have been
actual fighting if it weren't for a man
named solomon epstein
sometime around 2213 he makes a
breakthrough
and develops what will become to be
known as the epstein drive
it's a modified fusion drive and it
makes it possible for humanity to start
to
colonize the solar system as you can
imagine this was really valuable
technology
and mars decides to exchange the epstein
drive
share it with the un in exchange for
independence
from there the martian congressional
republic is formed
in the next few generations the un and
mars
start to spread out into the solar
system they go to the asteroid belt they
start to extract
resources and over the years
colonization continues to expand
places like ganymede show up at this
time to become
an agricultural center for the outer
planets
and in those generations we start to see
differences
appear in the bodies of people who are
developing
in low gravity this is where we get the
differences between
inners and belters there starts to be a
slight difference between earthers
and people who grew up on mars as well
it's in this period where the division
lines between the three factions in our
story become
clearly defined earth is the birthplace
of humanity
it's the home world it's the superpower
in the system
they've got a lot of problems on the
planet itself but they still have
incredible power
mars has embarked on a generations long
terraforming project
but something like that is just so far
down the road
to counteract some of that power that
earth has in their superpower status
mars has set out to build a powerful
navy of their own
and of course some advanced military
tech and some badass marines to go with
it
and out in the belt a lot of the people
who went out there to try to strike it
rich
are finding themselves as an exploitable
class of labor
the fact that these anatomical
differences start to happen
when you can visibly see a difference in
someone who grew up in the outer planets
that makes it even easier for them to be
otherwise they might be people but
they're not earthers
or even martians for that matter so a
life in the belt is one that's defined
by oppression
this leads to the creation of the outer
planet's alliance
at around the turn of the 24th century
at around 2330
timmy becomes amos and leaves earth
around that same time filipinaros is
born
and not long after that the august and
gemara is destroyed
by marco and his fledgling faction of
radical opa
at this time alex would be doing his 20
years that he did in the navy
christian avasarala would be moving her
way up the ranks through the un
government
and in the late 2330s james holden will
join the un's navy
and leave earth in 2339 u.n marine
colonel fred johnson
led a raid on anderson station to retake
it from striking workers
a lot of people died including civilians
who lived there
and he became infamous earning the title
the butcher of anderson station
after learning that his superiors set
him up he resigns
and eventually is recruited into the opa
by anderson
dawes so in 2342 mars surveys phoebe
and discovers the proto-molecule they
partner with a corporation called
protogen
in order to set up a long-term facility
to investigate what this substance that
they found
is a couple years later james holdren is
dishonorably discharged from the navy
after that he goes and gets himself a
job with the pure and clean water
company
and about five years later where the
series starts
he's working on an ice hauler called the
canterbury
before we get into the timeline of
events of the main story
i just want to say that of course they
play out a little bit differently
between the books and the show
in this video i'm gonna lean more
towards the show because that's what
people are more familiar with
but with the caveat that while the
details are different they both end up
in the same place overall
so at the beginning of the story the
future crew of the rasanante
are all working on the canterbury at the
same time julie mao boards a ship called
the scopuli and they go looking for a
ship called the anubis
because she believes a weapon her
father's working on is on that
ship she thinks if they can get a hold
of that they can make sure that this
weapon is never used against the belters
when they find the anubis they're
surprised to learn that it's a stealth
ship which they have no chance against
and the scopuli basically has to
surrender
julie's taken prisoner and she's put in
a room while the crew of the anubis
tries to figure out what to do with her
protogen then uses the scopula to send
out a fake distress signal
which the canterbury responds to holden
naomi alex
amos and shed take a shuttle called the
knight to investigate
while they're doing that the anubis
arrives and destroys the canterbury
protogen is doing this in a plan to
increase tensions between
earth and mars so that they can continue
to do their proto-molecule research
without any interruption
because of the anubis stealth tech and
the distressed call coming from a
martian made beacon
everyone on the night begins to believe
that mars may be behind the attack on
the cant
when the mcrn donager responds to the
night's distress call
holden sends out a message saying that
there was martian naval tech planted on
the scopuli
so he inadvertently plays into
protogen's plan
the survivors on the night are picked up
by the martian vessel
it's attacked by more stealth ships but
they're able to escape on a frigate
that's stalked inside that's named the
tachi
the martian marine who helped them
escape dies shortly after
and so now holden naomi alex and amos
have their own ship
fred johnson from the opa reaches out to
them and tells them that they can come
to taiko station
in that process the tachi becomes the
rasanante
timeline wise season one happens pretty
fast space travel does take
time but in julie's flashback episode we
learned that the scopulae
encountered the anubis seven weeks prior
to the rossi crew
and detective miller discovering her on
eros
after her body's discovered protogen
moves forward with their plan to conduct
an experiment with the proto-molecule on
a large population
they intentionally contaminated the
citizens of eros
and exposed them to radiation to speed
up the effects
season one of the show ends with them
setting up the experiment
where they can observe what'll happen
when the proto-molecule has that much
biomass to work with there's no time
jump in between seasons
because season one doesn't complete the
first book i'm glossing over the
political and military tensions and
engagements between the three factions
because they're somewhat different books
to show but we do see
phoebe station destroyed by mars in the
beginning of season 2.
in the big picture things are working
out for protogen
and jules pierre mao up until the crew
of the rossi
detective miller and fred johnson launch
a raid on toss station
this is where anthony dresden was
coordinating the aeros experiment
and after the raid is completed miller
executes dresden
from there they make a plan to push eros
into the sun
using the mormon colony ship the navoo
as a battering ram they also plan to rig
eros with explosives
and in the process of that miller gets
stuck there just before the naboo
crashes into eros
it's able to move out of the way and
then it starts accelerating towards
earth
this leads to the un firing off a bunch
of missiles in its direction
but on eros miller goes looking for
julie because he's been hearing her
voices in the sounds
of the protomolecule in the station he's
able to find what is basically her
consciousness in a body made out of
proto-molecule and he's able to
communicate
convincing her to guide eros into venus
instead of earth
the station crashes to the surface of
the planet
and this is where josephus miller dies
this is the end of the first book but it
happens in the middle of season two
of the show and this is where the
timeline of the show starts to get
condensed and they diverge
in the first chapter of the second book
it says it's been
18 months since eros in the show it
seems somewhat seamless
as there isn't an indication of a lot of
time passing
the same things happen though kids start
to go missing
project caliban is going on they're
testing protomolecule human hybrids
and eventually one of those is released
leading to the conflict at ganymede
there one of the hybrids engages with
un and mcr forces on the ground
and that leads to engagement in space
where the orbital mirrors that focus
light on the planet are damaged and
start to fall to the surface
compromising the agricultural domes this
leads to an armistice summit on earth
bobby becomes disillusioned with mars in
relation to the handling of her reports
about the hybrid and ends up working
with abasarala
they meet with jules pierre mao on his
yacht and eventually escape on the
razorback
this eventually brings them in contact
directly with the rosinante crew
and that's when they all meet for the
first time on venus the science vessel
the arbor gas
is deconstructed and absorbed into what
the proto-molecule is building there
hostilities break out around io where
work on the proto-molecule hybrids is
continuing
this will turn out to be the last stand
of jules pierre mal
and the people who are loyal to him
there's an attempt to launch
proto-molecule hybrids at mars which is
stopped and jules pierre mao
is taken into custody after that the
protomolecule project on venus
emerges from the planet and launches
itself towards
the outer planets just beyond uranus it
becomes a ring gate and this event
brings the inner planets back together
as all efforts are focused on trying to
understand what it is
this is the transition between the
second and third books
again the condensing of the timeline is
a little vague here
sometimes should have passed while it
was traveling from venus to uranus
and then also for the next event which
is the ek
slingshotting into the ring in the show
we see that it takes the fleet going to
investigate the rings
more than six months after it appeared
to get there
when they do the ring is opened after
the ek has flown into it
clarissa mao sets her plan in motion to
set up holden by blowing up the sung
yoon
the rosannante becomes the first ship to
enter the ring
and survive as they're being chased down
by a torpedo from the behemoth and then
all the ships outside the ring gate
follow after entering the ring space
ever since the ring assembled holden has
been seeing
visions of the investigator what looks
like detective miller
he convinces him to go to the ring
station
and go inside to help him access the
records
while he's there they both learn about
what happened to the ring builder
civilization how they were wiped out in
an instant by the unknown aggressors
while they were going to the center of
the station they were being pursued by
martian marines
and through acting like a threat they
caused the speed limit outside to be
slowed down
again this set up a situation where all
the ships need to
power down so they no longer appear as a
threat to the security system on the
station
and after they do that the investigator
is able to turn
off the system eliminating the speed
limit in the slow zone
this is the end of the third book and
the third season
and the ross ante agrees to transport
clarissa mao
back to luna so she can be arrested for
her crimes
this is a months-long journey and this
is where amos and clarissa form their
friendship
moving into season four this is the
first time we see
a one-to-one adaptation as season four
just covers the fourth book more or less
in the books a lot of time passes
because these are long journeys but the
show again seems to condense things a
little
the time they spend on illus isn't very
long most of the time that goes by would
have happened on their trip there in the
way back
what happens is a group of refugees from
ganymede run the blockade on the rings
and make it to the surface of a planet
which they call illus
abasarala is trying to stop a mad rush
through the ring gates because that will
essentially destabilize mars
so she sends the rasanante to act as a
mediator between the belters that
already
are there and an earth corporation that
has a charter to extract lithium from
the planet
secretly she hopes that things will fall
apart hold and being there won't help
anything
and he'll actually broadcast how
precarious things are whenever you try
to rush out to one of these worlds but
that doesn't work out
back when the hybrid was on the rossi it
left behind some active proto-molecule
and that's what was acting as a node on
the network making it possible for
the investigator to appear to hold it so
when the rossi went to illis
the investigator was able to activate
all the protomolecule tech on the planet
in the process of that he realized that
there was
a magic bullet left behind from the
unknown aggressors and that was a weapon
they used against the ring builder
civilization
he's able to use that to deactivate
everything he turned on
an avert crisis for everyone on the
planet before he does that he tells
holden to destroy the active
proto-molecule on the rossi
to make sure something like that doesn't
happen in the future
so on ellis things did get pretty bad
but almost everyone survived this is the
opposite of what abasarala was hoping
would happen
seeing that the situation was survivable
and that the belters had a ship full of
lithium that they'll be
bringing back to cell only increased
enthusiasm for people wanting to
colonize the planets on the other side
of the ring gates by destroying the
active proto-molecule on the raw seed
this trip marks the end of holden's
connection to the blue goo
so from there we get into season five
and the fifth book and the rossi returns
the soul system
where the ship will have to be repaired
and that's going to take about six
months
the crew splits up at this time and so
if we look at the timeline
you could make it work that this is 2355
like it showed on the opening screen
at the end of season 4 we saw the free
navy get stealth tech and put the plan
to throw rocks at earth in motion but we
don't know when that happened in
relation to
the rossi's return trip to soul system
in other words some time may have passed
between when ashford was spaced and when
they launched the rocks
and i mentioned that because at the
beginning of season five we see that
it's been
nearly six months after the rocks have
been launched from there the events that
happen in season five happen pretty
quickly
in the books they say that it takes amos
and clarissa about 14 days to get from
the prison
to baltimore and everything else happens
concurrently
so the rocks hit earth tycho station is
attacked fred johnson is killed the
breakaway martian fleet burns towards
the ring
and at the end of the fifth season we
have the battle for soul gate
and the bar keith disappearing as it
passes through the laconia ring
in the show's version of events we lose
our first rossi crew member
too when alex strokes out after a
hygiene maneuver
this hasn't happened in the books yet
the actor who portrayed him was fired by
the show
after more than 40 allegations of abuse
and harassment made by fans and
co-workers
so they decided to kill him off three
major things happen in season five the
asteroid attack against
earth the breakaway martian fleet taking
fred johnson's protomolecule sample
and passing through the ring gates to
the laconia system where they planned to
start their own civilization
using the protomolecule to help them
advance
and the rise of the free navy and soul
system where they took control of medina
station which means they now have
control of any traffic going through the
rings
by the end of working on this i can say
i understand why the authors chose to
keep the timeline vague when they
developed the story
there aren't many examples of blatant
discrepancies in the timelines of the
books
things mostly make sense when you look
at it closely but there is a lot of
discussion about whether some of the
travel times that show up there
are correct or not and i'm not a math
guy so that's beyond my
skill set one of the first things i
noticed when i started looking at the
timeline in the past
is that most of what happens inside any
of the books happens pretty quickly and
then the real time passes in between
when they're traveling or if there's
just down time between where one book
ends and the next one picks up
based on the obvious markers i think the
timeline of the books through number
five
is between eight to eleven years and the
show seems to condense that into a
five-year span
and i think that is a great place to
leave things we can continue the
conversation in the comments so make
sure to let me know what you think what
do you think of the timeline
do you think it should take longer like
it did in the books or do you like how
the show condensed things down
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon